the conversation's great yeah but i
think we do need to maybe
start to figure out if someone is trying
to hide in the conversation so what
would you suggest sam
see yeah that was it we brought together
six white people and one fake white
person
i am asian if the group discovers who
the liar is
they'll win a cash prize if the liar
survives
they win the cash prize with no cameras
and only audio
can they find the fake this is odd man
out
so i don't think there's anything that
will
really tell me if someone isn't white
hopefully mentioning that i don't live
in the us won't get me eliminated
immediately but we'll see how things go
i feel like the mole is going to have
prepared a lot of things
and have a little bit of an act going i
wrote up my life
and printed it out this is gonna be so
exciting let's go
does everyone want to say like where
they're from and like whatever i'm from
spanish alabama i'm from argentina and
i'm from san diego california i'm from
indiana originally but i live in south
korea and i'm from
kind of near london i am from outside of
chicago i'm in like the new york
area have we all done ancestry.com i
feel like that's a place to start i've
done an ancestry
yeah i've done it yeah yeah i'm like 60
60 english 30 dutch so like an exotic
combination of white and white
35 irish and then like kind of split
between italian and german
33 german 33 swedish and 53
english so half italian 30 irish and
then there's like some
fun german greek norway scottish in
there so like i got a fun assortment of
whiteness
we love that i got like 50 french 25
irish and 25 polish i am mostly
norwegian
and then the rest is uh mixed up between
swedish and irish
yeah actually i'm the i'm the odd one
here i haven't done ancestry but
my uh i know my ancestry so we're
scottish in english
that's white man let's see what kind of
like foods do y'all like i guess we
could talk about that
uh i don't know if it plays in my favor
being not like
white food necessarily but i i'm a big
fan of japanese food
really into like ramen and sushi i like
sushi
i'll try a bit of everything i guess um
i quite like chinese food
i almost always hated like italian food
like a lot of pasta a lot of lasagna i
like pasta too
i eat a lot of korean food but korean
food is spicy so often they'll go into
restaurants and they'll look at me and
they'll be like no it's too spicy for
foreigners
and i'm like no give it to me i feel
like being white like i have a good
like house like yeah yeah yeah yeah we
eat a lot of spicy foods around here too
lots of hot sauce
what brand of hot sauce oh what brand uh
man you know what i don't know i i i we
kind of go with whatever
attracts us on the shelf but we have i
don't know 20 different hot sauces in
the fridge right now so
when we were talking about hot sauces
and i heard somebody go interesting
i'm most suspicious of rob great voice
by the way
would definitely listen to your podcast
i think i'm just going to vote for
lauren
i don't know i will vote for sam but i
feel quite bad about that
wendy ross i feel like people are gonna
vote for rob going after
rob and his hot sauces lauren you get my
vote fingers crossed the votes are in
and we have a
tie between rob and lauren
each person has 20 seconds to state
their case rob
you're up first well i can't believe i'm
in a tie already here
guys i don't understand why you would
vote me out we want to try to get the
mole
out first and i am clearly not the mole
i
my strategy was to get them all out
early and then we can fight it out for
who's going to end up with the prize
money but getting me out early
it decreases your chances because you've
got a mole still
sitting in there with you he didn't say
anything to actually prove it
he just kind of went not me i don't
think so do i know how i'm white
because whenever anything needs to be
returned my like in my family
my family will give whatever to my
grandma because one
she's like an old white woman and she's
also a scorpio so she gets things
returned for us regardless of receipt or
not why do i know that because i'm white
i'm a caucasian thank you very much i
only need 19.
it's going to be rob i think so i think
i would just go with lauren so i think
i'm going to vote for rob
sorry rob okay the votes are in
and the person eliminated in round one
is
rob oh why do i think i was eliminated i
don't know
maybe it's my smooth voice
do you guys like feel like there's a
white culture i don't think there's
specifically a white culture
everyone has their own culture so like
me being white english is a different
culture from a white american to you
know a white
a white german or white australian why
are you argentinian yeah is that here
at least being a white person i don't
have strong ties to like my english or
dutch heritage i more strongly identify
with the culture i grew up like in the
midwest
and now living as an expat abroad i
agree completely
with that most of my school growing up
was white and it wasn't really until
i moved to texas i'm at ut now it wasn't
until i got here that i really got to
see like
you know what diversity even really
means okay so here i think the
the conversation's great yeah but i
think we do need to maybe get to a
couple things that we could
start to figure out if someone is trying
to hide in the conversation or something
like that
so what would you suggest sam see yeah
that was i was like i'm gonna say this
but then also i don't have anything to
share with them
say your face what's the whitest thing
about you i mean i don't know this is
like a
i guess it could be like a white
stereotype but i'm really into like
cheesy reality tv shows like
the bachelor oh my gosh i try not to
watch that kind of stuff but when i do
start watching it i get um
i get hooked yeah it's hard to start
yeah they are they are
very addictive a lot of the time the
people
that speak a lot can be the mole because
he spoke
the least i'll be going for ross yeah i
think i'm gonna vote for sam just
because he was like quiet
i feel like i probably will be voting
for lauren again but i'm going to go
vote for sam i'm going after the guys i
think i'll go with sam again yeah i
voted sam
we have counted all the votes and the
person eliminated this round
is sam
hey i had my shot and it really didn't
go well that sucks
i wanted to know uh if you have any
experiences
uh with white privilege as i said i'm
from argentina
i grew up it was mostly eighty percent
wide it's down to sixty five percent
wide
i never really realized what a white
privilege was until i
left the country the first time i went
to the us and i noticed
the difference one of my really good
friends is a mixed race and then
i have a podcast and we were talking on
the podcast during the black lives
matter
things in the summer he spoke about
things that i didn't notice
i think it's good that in the world now
especially the last
few years people are realizing yeah i
feel like we're making progress but
there's still just
so much more out there and like it's
true like if i get pulled over like the
first thing that goes through my mind is
not like
you know scaredness or anything like
like that it's more just like
i'm gonna be okay which is really sad
i've been pulled over and sort of been
scurried away i feel like being white at
least in america it's like we always
just have
one up in the situation yeah like
they're like a lot of people are like
sort of steps behind us like
racism and slavery has like had so many
insidious effects
like i've had the interesting experience
of going from being
a majority in you know midwestern us
to being a minority here even among the
minorities there's still a hierarchy
i have more privileges as a white
american even though i'm a foreigner
than other people of color who's here
all of my
experiences are not comparable to those
experienced by people of color here who
have it far worse
i was suspicious of ross but not anymore
and i'm gonna go
korean don't ask me why i just i have to
choose someone
i'm gonna go for ross um i don't know he
didn't really talk that much
sorry ross i will go for kristen i might
vote for wendy i think i might be going
this round
oh god it's hard it's hard we counted
all the votes and the person eliminated
this round is
ross i knew it oh no the girls are going
up against us
um obviously disappointed um i think i
was kind of getting onto something but
it is what it is okay if everyone feels
confident that you already caught them
all
you can end the game now if the majority
has doubt
the game will continue i am afraid that
if i can't continue the game i
will be eliminated i don't want to be
eliminated
please vote in three two
one
okay would you guys say that you're like
proud to be white oh that has like i
feel like that has a lot of negative
connotation i know see it's hard because
it's like
obviously you're not proud of like you
know the past i mean i think it's sort
of like a paradoxical statement you know
like the kkk and like proud boys now
exactly
yeah what do we say like white like you
know white power and like all that
i'm not proud to be white i just happen
to be white i've benefited
from it um but i don't have strong
identities to
my white heritage it's very sad to say
that i always
growing up it was just normal i really
started questioning
what what was so normal about wayne
white way later in life so it's kind of
i don't really again i don't think too
much about being white it's just
i feel like it is what it is it's the
same i'm blonde i'm white i have brown
eyes it's just
all part of the same deal like it's just
an adjective
and it's like different because like
people say like i'm proud to be black i
feel like that comes from a place of
like
you know the history that you know
they've had to overcome so much yeah
yeah and it's like what have we
overcome y'all we're talking about such
deep issues and it's obviously not being
white it comes to my mind like it's not
my place to talk about this but at the
same time
these are issues that everyone in
society you know
faces and sees i think the fact that we
all voted
to continue it means that we are all
white
i guess i'll be voting for corinne just
because she was the
least aggressively white person of the
bunch i'm gonna go with corinne probably
it's just fall right it's hard but yeah
i think i'm gonna go with wendy
here goes nothing we have counted all
the votes and the person eliminated in
round four
is corrine no
y'all dang that sucks
i want to know like what what it was if
everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all
you can end the game now if the majority
has doubt the game will continue
i think we're good i'm done with this i
i'm done i want to
finish victories yeah we all said no
if the color that shows up is green you
all win if it shows red
the mole is still in the game and you
all lost in
three two one
here we go the game is over and the
white people have won
that means that the winners will be
receiving a cash prize and we're also
going to be gifting them the akintu
experience where they will be able to
pick their favorite basics from our new
interactive apparel brand
now i would like everyone to turn on
their cameras and we'll reveal who the
mole really was
turn on your cameras in three two
one hey y'all
you girls were going up against us guys
weren't you i thought of that i was like
it was unintentional so my real name is
fariha
and i'm actually indian we didn't even
brought it bring it brought up like last
names or anything like that like i had a
good full name prepared oh my god what
was it
my middle name was beth and my last name
was walker
yeah that's pretty white i'm glad i got
to be a part of this video to just
kind of hear from different people than
how like their background
has affected their perspective on being
white
on the world in general you know i mean
i feel like there isn't really one one
size fits all or one
collective experience my culture is not
defined by how
i look it's more defined by where i live
and where i grew up there's a lot of
white privilege and if you don't think
that's real
you're not paying attention is it
something that i relish in no
i i don't think it's fair and i wish we
could eliminate all that i wish we could
even the playing field
and just say you know what we're all
human let's just be cool to each other
[Music]
you